it is November 11 2022 and you're
watching the code report no great
JavaScript framework would be complete
without its own meta framework for
server-side rendering to go along with
it react has next view has next angular
has analog spelltas kit quick has City
and as of yesterday solid has start as a
late Comer to the JavaScript framework
War it has the luxury of taking the best
features from its peers and puts them
together into one beautiful package and
refreshingly it graciously gives all of
them Credit in its announcement blog
like when the Germans use mustard gas in
World War one I don't seem to recall the
French giving them any credit when they
totally copied this game-changing
blazingly deadly feature I think it says
a lot about the team behind solid giving
credit where credit is due but they've
also done a lot of their own Innovation
with a UI framework that's already very
solid like other meta Frameworks it uses
file system routing and supports nested
layouts in the same way that nux does
where a file can Shadow a directory that
then has an outlet component that
projects all the content from the
subrouts this differs from next 13 which
has a layout file for each of your
layouts both nexjs and spell kit have a
variety of naming conventions for the
files in the routing system but one
major criticism of this is that it leads
to a bunch of files with the same name
in your project like you'll have a
hundred page.js files solid start takes
the approach more like the old next JS
where a file name will represent a route
and it even takes things one step
further where instead of having a bunch
of index files you can wrap the file
name in parentheses to give it a more
descriptive name that's pretty cool but
things get a lot more interesting when
we start talking about data fetching
like many other meta Frameworks you can
export a function in this case called
route data that can fetch data on the
server or client when the user navigates
to a new route what felt kind of weird
at first to me was that you also need to
use this create route data function that
takes a callback that does the actual
data fetching my initial thought was why
not just simplify this API and return
the data from the route data function
but it turns out there's a good reason
for this that will make sense in just a
minute but first after we fetch this
data we can then go into the UI
component and access it with the use
route data hook while providing us with
end-to-end type safety now it doesn't
just return the object itself but rather
a resource the resource has useful
properties on it like loading that we
can use with built-in components like
show to easily handle the loading UI
that's extremely useful but things get
even better if we go back into the
create route data function it also takes
a second argument that contains one or
more keys which allows you to refetch
this data in a granular way later if
you've ever used react query this will
feel very familiar for example we can
use the refetch route data function with
that key without needing to reload the
entire page and we can also do more
advanced things with it like optimistic
updates and handle multiple data
Fetchers at the same time that's what
data fetching looks like but what about
mutations first I'll point out that you
can create API routes anywhere in the
project by simply exporting a function
that has a matching HTTP verb like we
could export API routes from the same
file we can't do a git request here
because the component's already doing
that but we could easily add a git API
route from any other file that's pretty
cool but we can also set up our PC or
remote procedure calls directly in a
component there's a function called
server with a dollar sign the dollar
sign representing that it only runs on
the server and that gives us a way to
write server-side code literally
anywhere without having to create a new
file and follow a bunch of restful API
conventions that we don't really need
this is a really cool Innovation by
solidstar that I think has the potential
to really simplify the way we think
about server-side code in a meta
framework like this but we're not done
yet the framework also has actions very
similar to remix actions allow you to
mutate data and when the mutation is
complete it will automatically refetch
the existing data on the page and it
also provides an object to monitor the
state of that update I really appreciate
their emphasis on data fetching because
that tends to be the hardest thing to
get right and when you get it right it
often eliminates the need for these
wacky wavy inflatable armed flailing
State Management systems that can often
lead developers to an involuntary
72-hour psychiatric hold the bottom line
is that solid start could be your best
hope for survival if you are a refugee
fleeing the war torn react ecosystem it
only ships five kilobytes of JavaScript
as opposed to nearly 80 for next JS it
doesn't have a shadow Dom and is true
truly reactive watch my 100 second video
for more details on that because if we
don't end this war this war will end us
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one